so Chris Nolan is here at comic-con for
the first time ever oh so when he's got
some big superhero IP that he knows the
geeks will see he doesn't deign to grace
us with his presence but when he's got
his own original IP science fiction
movie suddenly he's here hat in hand I
don't think so sir I guess what I'm
saying is I didn't get into the panel
where people got to see the new trailer
with footage from the alien planet man
it would be terrible if somebody leaked
their bootleg footage of that new
interstellar trailer and sent me the
link awful in high definition would be
terrible with good color contrast and
saturation I don't know what I'd do if
somebody sent that to me I would be so
disheartened I wouldn't even report the
copyright violation I have two people
with excellent costumes here can you
tell me who you are lekin arief romero
that stroke from arrow great costumes I
can't watch the show because it takes
far too many liberties with the source
material so I am literally red faced
with rage about Avengers age of Ultron
actually I'm probably red-faced because
of this strange glowing disk in the sky
above San Diego III don't know what it
is I just know I'm never going outside
again what infuriates me is on the
marvel panel elizabeth Olsen mistakenly
referred to her character as a mutant
then had to back up and correct herself
and call her character a mutated person
that makes me outraged because her
character is a mutant but the studio
that owns x-men has the rights to the
word mutant as well as to the concept of
adamantium I know I've said Marvel
properties are too jumbled spend too
much time promoting each other but I
take it all back I want all elements of
the Marvel Universe to be combined in a
single thread spider-man x-men Avengers
wrap mall together in one big ball
you